now Governor DeSantis as I mentioned
will be delivering his State of the
State address tomorrow by the way his
brand new book the courage to be free is
ready a number one bestseller he is now
joining us Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
Governor great to have you back thank
you
good evening Sean thanks for having me
let's just start with what I think just
is so glaring to me you know for 175
years uh the state of California they
always gain population people would move
to the Golden State you know move west
Etc that is now not only stopped the
last three years they're losing almost a
thousand residents uh a day while you're
gaining nearly a thousand residents a
day tell us how why you think this is
happening
well Sean you hit on the nail on the
head I mean for about 175 years
Americans built the path to California
no one left California it probably has
more natural advantages than any state
in the country I as a naval officer
actually spent time stationed at
Coronado uh outside of San Diego
absolutely beautiful place and yet when
I became Governor we started for the
first time in Florida seeing California
license plates in our state and I can
tell you A lot of my supporters were
spooked because they didn't know how
these people were going to vote well it
turns out a lot of these folks were
people like us they were disaffected by
the bad policies they were upset at the
taxation they were upset about how the
government operated they were upset
about crime and these Soros back
District Attorneys letting criminals run
wild and they were very frustrated with
the covid lockdown policy so it created
a really perfect storm for people to
uproot themselves and move across the
entire United States to places like
Florida and I tell you I always ask them
Sean because it's one thing to move from
the north to a warmer climate
California's got good weather say are
you glad you did it and all of them so
far that I've talked to have been glad
that they've moved to Florida
let me ask you about this battle with
Gavin Newsom uh he actually said these
words Welcome to the Real Freedom state
California that's what he said you
responded by saying that well great
Gavin your state is hemorrhaging
population of my state of Florida
um you uh have gone out there on the
record and said that the at your
immigration plan would invalidate
Governor newsom's ID for illegal
immigrants nuisance shot back that Ronda
Santos is using migrants as pawns
um uh isn't he aren't Sanctuary States
aren't they aiding and abetting law
breaking isn't it still against the law
to enter this country without proper
permission
of course in Florida we're not a
sanctuary State when I became Governor
we were able to ban Sanctuary cities uh
the rule of law is important and so of
course we're not going to recognize uh
Lawless identifications that are done uh
by California and California they've
abandoned the rule of law they are a
sanctuary State they don't follow
Federal immigration laws and of course
the Soros prosecutors they pick and
choose which laws to enforce there'll be
people in Los Angeles who will get mugs
Sean on the street and the prosecutor
won't bring charges against these guys
and they end up going out and they
victimize other people so I think Public
Safety is incredibly important and when
you abandon the rule of law you end up
getting a lot of the results that
they've had in California and people
respond by fleeing the jurisdiction
Governor you you've taken on the issue
of woke ideology the fight of wolf
ideology as you call it and you said
that you are not content to just keep
taxes low and stay out of anything else
and that you mean you believe that woke
ideology is pernicious and that your
policies are helping to protect people
from having the woke ideology shoved
down their throats in institution after
institution after institution now we see
this in education we see this pretty
much in in almost every aspect of life
What specifically are you talking about
when you say woke ideology
so what we're doing we're doing a couple
things Sean one just the recognition you
know I can win a landslide election by
1.5 million votes and yet the left can
still try to impose its agenda through
all these other avenues to society so we
recognize that threat more than just
what happens in the legislature
obviously you need to win those fights
so for example uh we've done things like
ban critical race theory in our K-12
schools no gender ideology of course we
got in the tussle with Disney but second
graders shouldn't be told that they were
born in the wrong body and now with our
public universities we are eliminating
these Dei programs which are basically
ideological indoctrination they are
racially discriminatory and it's spread
like wildfire throughout almost every
college in the United States so we're
upholding the concept of individual
Merit treating people as individuals and
based on the content of their character
not trying to divvy up people uh by race
as part of some woke sweepstakes
let me talk about the issue of the two
issues that came up that became
controversies and you were you came
under Fire over uh for example education
K through third grade only the issue of
CRT and gender identity you said will
not be taught in schools and many of
your critics tried to call that the
don't say gay Bill the word gay was not
in the bill correct me if I'm wrong
no exactly I mean this was a narrative
that was put out by the left and it was
not true but you know the corporate
press I mean they're very partisan and
so they took it and even to this day
when clearly it's not an accurate
description of what happens they these
Outlets will refer to it that way now
here's the thing Sean we had a
referendum on this on the election I can
tell you parents across Florida
regardless of political party uh agreed
with us that we need to focus our
education on the basics teaching kids to
read write teaching them to add subtract
teaching about Science and History we
don't need to be injecting Concepts like
gender ideology into the schools
particularly the young kids
let me ask you about the CRT debate
because that became an opportunity your
critics people on the left uh you know
they love to throw around the the r word
people are racist uh when I looked at
the course itself and the tenants that
were being taught and discussed uh CRT
these are their words not mine and uh
quote black queer studies they call them
um why would this be taught in school
why is this even being discussed and
what I'm having a hard time
understanding why it's even
controversial why is there this push
that doesn't sound like education to me
that's not reading writing Math Science
History computers uh or preparing
somebody for a career that to me sounds
like an agenda that is far different
than anything educational that would
serve an educational purpose
it's pure indoctrination and it's
effectively neo-marxism they're trying
to jam queer Theory into this they're
trying to jam uh Concepts like CRT and
so that runs a foul of our standards so
the Florida Board of Education rejected
that proposed AP course but you know the
media lied about that too Sean they
tried to say that in the State of
Florida you know they don't want to
teach you about different aspects of
African-American history when in reality
our state law and our state standards
require teaching all aspects of U.S
history including history involving
African Americans from slavery on uh and
so we're doing it right because that's
factual history but we're not going to
let them hijack that to try to advance a
left-wing agenda I know it's the
question that a lot of people have been
asking and there's a lot of speculation
that you might be getting into the 2024
presidential race
um I know your answer I hate to ask
questions that I think I know the answer
to what is your answer
foreign
I appreciate it as you know I had my
State of the State tomorrow we've got a
great legislative session coming up I
mean we ran won a big victory swept in a
lot of people to office uh that's a
Vindication of what we did the last four
years was also an opportunity so we're
really laser focused on that as you
mentioned we do have the book the
courage to be free uh give us a few
months on that I think we're going to
put up a lot of wins and then we'll be
in a better position uh to make a
decision about the future is it fair to
say you're thinking about it
I think it's fair to say that I have
people coming up to me and asking me to
do it all the time uh I'm very good
about just putting one step in front of
the other and focusing on the task at
hand so I don't get too far down the
field with anything I gotta execute the
mission right here and as we get beyond
that we'll take a look yeah I have
people coming up to me all the time not
asking me that question I can promise
you that uh anyway Governor good luck
with your State of the State address
tomorrow thank you for being with us we
appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else